you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Lee chest
org and I just got paired up playing a
3-2 game happy New Year to you all
January 1st 2016 3 2 with a sicilian
alright let's go for an open Sicilian
see what we get here ok let's try for an
English attack might be 3 f3 my cup of
tea but let's mix it up somehow we're
going to be going after one another's
Kings a5 ok let's play a four yeah a
four and Bishop to b5 maybe I'm not
certain if I should play that right away
maybe I could get on with g4 g5 Knight B
4 and then a d5 break is lined up let's
shoot for g4 right now try to rattle the
knight position I don't have too much
experience playing on the white end with
this
maybe I should immediately give him a
kick yeah let's do it
all right now King b1 is pretty common
I would think or maybe just still start
pushing pieces huh let's try h4 this
would be quite natural rook c8 it'll be
hitting soon King b1 there's pressure on
here okay maybe now they should be 5 or
no I don't really need it just yet huh
that Knights going to arrive on c4 soon
and I wonder about Queen of - maybe I
could have you considered that on the
last move
although I'd be dropping g5 Queen f2
pushing my pawns let's let's try this
I guess Knight c4 is gonna hit soon I
think c4 I have to take I can't allow
them to take my dark square bishop on d5
I think I could take on b6 and then take
on e5 hmm let's see this is a super
strong piece can't really work with a
knight on that square and this is one of
the reasons why I didn't want to
initially declare my light square bishop
I want to be able to take a piece out in
just one move okay that's a bit of a
surprising move hmm okay let's take like
this let's get the G file I guess rook
takes and then around this okay I
pressure on f3 how do I deal with that
hmm I wonder
yeah cuz Queen F to Knight c4 takes I'm
going right into a pin as well
mm-hmm this is tricky um let's try Queen
f2 not really a big fan of this move but
to go with something Knight c4 I'm
pretty sure I still have to take that
night just striking at this heart of my
structure on the Kings side threatening
Bishop takes Knight right now so pretty
limited let's take him out and maybe
Knight to d2 or oh you know what I
missed this resource I had Knight c5 and
maybe I still can be playing that hmm
because there's this pin on the D file
I'm just noticing that now let's play
King b1 yeah I think I had this much
sooner I
you know what no only after I played
Queen 2f2 did I have this idea in mind
so it's something to still keep an eye
on it's night c-5 idea for as long as
the black Queens on the D file really
not sure how to proceed here I mean this
is quite common I would think actually
oh that's really getting sharp now huh
Wow okay so they're gonna push their a
pawn right down my throat is that the
big idea I guess it is I could throw in
Bishop to b6 however and maybe Queen f8
mm-hmm let's go with this I'm gonna take
and push a four I guess so and I have
this move and maybe now I should go for
it
Knights c5 maybe into a six let's give
it a shot
I should think about getting on this
diagonal soon it'll hit with the check
mm-hmm getting pretty scary
b3 just take hmm I could also hit the
night with something mm-hmm I'm gonna go
with this try and keep the a file closed
it's tough my queen is going to be
restricted soon to defending c2 not fun
okay yeah rook takes here is already an
idea oh boy
rook takes c3 and I think it's game over
okay I didn't even realize I had this
Knight move until right now I think Rick
takes here is still available you know
I'm in big trouble after that because
then they could take the bishop next
let's do this
I kick that night out of there let's
give him a kick and then take on a to
move real sharp game gotta get rid of
that ape on no or let's make sure I get
rid of the Queens take with the pond all
right I have to defend b3 and my bishop
maybe Bishop b6 was better yeah let's
play that I got to start pushing these
ponds it's a big race it's a big race
before their night is a bit out of play
right there my B pond as well to kind of
kill him that's I probably could have
done something better than that I'm
gonna start pushing there King side
pawns hmm let's get one rook off I'm
gonna move my pawn anyway okay yeah
let's take and I think I have to get
this guy rolling c4 c5 yeah I just kept
pushing right away
and it will hit with tempo this night on
b7 okay King here mm-hmm
I don't want to draw let's get pushing
let's see who's faster I can't calculate
this of course all right you know and
King here get inch up for now let's do
this I have this square covered I
thought there was a knight check there
isn't I could keep advancing these
checks run out do they not d6 and then
c6
I think I could keep pushing there might
be an exchange sacrifice um
let's keep going hmm okay push with this
guy right okay what am I missing
these pawns are very dangerous start pre
moving sake there and get a queen hmm oh
okay that was not cool what just
happened there I gotta get this I don't
even know what just happened there and
yeah that's no good I have to try and
hold this to a draw I can't even make
sense of what just happened there okay I
think this is a draw now yeah I can't
even I'm gonna have to look back and see
what in the world just happened there Oh
okay let's just take here and we're
gonna I guess play on for just a little
bit more I'll just offer to draw yeah I
guess they offer to draw right at the
same time wow what just happened there
right they played rook there and I
promoted hmm yeah right okay I was in
pre move on this recapture then they did
that push I should immediately come down
here oh that was too much of a
nail-biter rook here stops the pawn and
then I could push through so rook to d1
and only then push wow that really
turned out to be a race normally it's a
race to kill one anothers king but then
it turned out to be
to passers get them pushing as soon as
possible and I probably could have saved
some time right around this point here
like this it moves like this this King
b3 move is like oh yeah just kind of
tuck your king in but I should I should
really just got pushing right away some
time wasted and I'm sure multiple
blunders for both sides so let's have a
quick look with the computer and it's
from on the local evaluation and see if
we could take a thing or two away from
this Sicilian defense Knight or
variation English attack let me adjust
that okay yeah let's see this graph hmm
okay that's some ups and downs here and
it towards that ending I guess I am
better I'm just a little bit faster and
then and then my opponent was winning at
some point towards the end yeah okay
yeah let's see if we could take a thing
or two away from this one so pretty even
stuff up to here this a five again I
don't have too much experience on the
white end here but yeah Bishop b5 no if
we could get too many good suggestions
from this point hmm a four I know a four
is a move just to preserve this Knight
position in the drawback of course is
that it weakens b4 and so that Queen
Knight hops right to it and then d5 is
that much closer to getting in so if you
have to act Swift I think one point to
know is this quite common move Bishop to
b5 I think can be I think there's an
idea connected with Knight ASAP
and if you move away with the bishop
then I think there's a move like this
I mean it's reading as plus one I might
have the I have the details a little bit
off with this but I've seen something
where your black tries to overtake the
be five square it might have actually
been with the knight plank here yeah I
think this is I think this was the move
where if as white now after Knight a6
Bishop b5 Knight c7 can be a move in
some cases yeah now it's even popping up
Knight c7 and for this reason maybe even
two slightly more accurate for the Queen
Knight is to not play to c6 but rather a
six just to have a more centralized
pivot Square to attack the be five
square it's true both c7 and a7 do this
but a knight on c7 it's more central and
you know what another way to get maybe
even look at it is that a knight on c7
let's say Bishop b5 a knight on c7 is
hitting both be five and still
facilitating this advance these are um
little details a lot of attention of
course on just the squares in the
position the squares and the Queen side
to be a bit more exact the weekend
square b5 in the weakened squares b4 and
b5 but okay in this one what happened I
played a 496 I get on with g4 it likes
h4 here but okay I went with g5 h for
Knight b6 Queen f2 is that what I played
now I continue to push huh so right now
Queen to F - how are things different
Queen f2 Knight c4 takes takes and then
calls for Bishop to b6 hmm
still even an even position Queen d7 oh
boy and now the computer is going pawn
hunting mmm that's not really a pond I'm
a big fan of taking it's giving open
lines for this some attack against my
own king so if the idea really is to
hunt down this pond with Bishop b6 yeah
don't know if I'm that big a fan of it
what would be maybe be some other idea
here I'm not really sure is something
like f4 available yes f4 with f5 f6
right now actually it's a threatening to
take taking advantage of this pin so you
know this is this is the more human-like
move let's just say therefore if you
compare Bishop d6 and f4
I'd be more inclined to play off for
okay just to have a little bit of an
idea because it's it's tough it's like
how do i improve my rip positions is
something like this an idea I really I
don't see that as being a good idea he's
a strong he's a reliable defender of d6
hmm yeah so f4 in this position after h4
Knight b6 I played h5 but an immediate
Queen f2 takes takes and then f5 is a
seems like a fine way to approach this
position okay sharp for sure doesn't
like f5 huh oh man you know what I
thought I didn't even consider this g6
idea I had it in my mind when we have
this situation with the pawns that any
pawn move I make they just make a pawn
move to keep it locked g6 met with H 6 H
6 met with g6 but I was forgetting that
I have a sacrifice on this square no
it's not going straight in for that
wouldn't this be fine though
no it wouldn't because I end up in a
fork which we can now see the idea was
king to be one it's giving them I'm not
so sure about this yeah f-for the King
side is now what it's locked down this
is where this is the side the board I
want to be playing on and I don't see
how to make further progress is however
the idea this is this is this is quite
interesting is the idea to eliminate the
light square bishop because then I could
see and I could see something where we
can pivot about on the d5 square with
the Peace King here I guess is taking
measures against Bishop here allowing to
allowing black to preserve this light
square Bishop Bishop h3 no it's ok with
that light square bishop exchange is it
I thought the idea with King there is to
tuck the bishop away not sure how
accurate we could how much we could rely
upon this evaluation I know I'm not
giving it a lot of time to think but uh
yeah it's a bit suspicious for sure I
mean just as a general rule I mean we're
trying to attack one another on I'm
trying to attack on the Kings side
blacks trying to attack on the Queen
side we both want the position to open
up we want open lines open files so this
idea of having the gene h5g file an
h-file closed and we have a situation
where black can also shut down the F
file like this all these instances of
fixed pawns on the Kings side kinda
doesn't doesn't seem right for white so
hmm okay they went with f5 g6 I'm not
sure about g6 ok I took still even queen
g2
I played Queen f7 still holding it as
even what's the difference between G -
maybe - think about this stuff okay
Queen f2 takes takes king b1 you know
what a sharp game in what can I say
takes gives me a pawn advantage but why
was it scary night c1 I played night c5
doesn't like that and I'd see one I
guess keep a pace around near my king
his defense
okay night c5 b3
yeah it's this is a very loose position
now it just seems to only be held
together by a thread I have a lot of
pieces that are restricted after I'm in
this position right here which I guess
is still fine it likes night a4 I played
night a4 but I thought here I know was I
was I thinking rook takes pawn could be
played at what point I was thinking
maybe at around this point there could
take within Knight takes c2 that's not
quite the case it takes pawn I take the
rook I think takes c2 King here it's a
bit scary for sure but they're not quite
pushing through successfully okay so
Ripa takes F 3 isn't it is not on Queen
a five-night a 4
you know I only saw this once the
position was presented on the board I
didn't even I'm not sure I actually I
was looking at the a6 square before I
was even considering Knight a 4 to
disrupt the coordination between the
rook and the pond but Knight a 4 cuts
off the influence both the Queen and
rook have with the a to pawn rook there
now it's liking team white
still okay Bishop g6 I want to get that
night out of there it seems okay with it
Queen d5 give something up with that but
yeah I just run the Queen's off at that
point
Wow take I'm surprised it's as even as
it is for so long in such a sharp
position Wow
and now it's a big race grab the pond
and it's liking black its liking white
we are both really low on time around
this point but the name of the game is
to get your pawns in motion C and D
pawns still holding it as even right
around this point it should be shifting
a real lot okay now this is getting
pretty serious on and a half advantage
better being Bishop to f8 maintaining
pressure here hmm okay with that I keep
pushing +4 now and he takes pawn rook
takes Bishop takes Knight takes push and
yeah this is where I couldn't even
recall what just happened when I was
playing rook to d1 I just pushed and
that throws away the ball game rook to
d1 I have a little bit of a concern of
this guy maybe being connected but you
know what he's a long way off is he not
rook f7 night here threatening to push
also Oh other details it stops the rook
from even getting to the eighth-ranked
so here now push here
there and is this pawn in time no it's
never in time if I wanted to I could
come over here right away but actually
even better as saying you know what I'm
not even allowing you
to exchange your up for my pond I will
be getting a queen okay so that's why
they actually pointed out king f7 here I
could push get a queen and yeah this I
could go right over and grab that pond
so what did happen because eventually it
did turn out where black was the better
side in the game chop I just pushed
instead of rook here I got a queen and
now okay well now I'm just losing
because what was better here to push
rook takes Queen and then rook to d1
rook to c3 okay yeah tough to see why
those are that this it's tough to see
why this is a better move oh well
it's preparing to get behind the pawn
for one it keeps the king cut off for a
moment it's another way to view it
because the Queen side of the board is
now turning irrelevant no pawns on that
side of the board the attention is
shifting towards the Kings side my king
wants to be on the Kings side rip there
cuts him off for at least a moment
preparing to maybe do this and then push
okay so Brooke f8 I get my king rolling
and they start pushing and towards the
end here yeah now it's at minus six
yeah this is what I thought they could
do I well I wasn't able to voice it
during the game but I thought yeah my
knight if I'm without him these two
pawns are greater than my rook but they
just pushed right away yeah the the
winning idea is to just take him out
King here you take the knight and then
you just push and he's crunched but they
were too quick to push their pawn there
and this allowed the draw wow what an
interesting game very sharp English tech
feel free to leave any feedback to this
one it's it was a nail-biter I hope you
enjoyed it and again a Happy New Year to
you all
okay I'll catch you in the next video
hope all is well take care bye
you